welcome everyone i'm sheriff joe
lombardo and we're going to have a
discussion
about the state of the department
[Music]
they take a security point
[Music]
[Music]
first i have to apologize to everyone
usually we do the state of the
department at the smith center and
whoever is available or desire
to come see me in person we like to
accommodate that
but this year covid everybody is aware
of the situation so i think it's
important for me still to address the
workforce
and you to hear directly from me on the
state of the department and where we're
going into the future you know the
purpose of the state of the department
is
discuss the highlights of the previous
year and where departments going into
the future so there's a couple things i
want to talk about
today is that is the strategic plan our
response to covet our current situation
with covid the budget
use of force and what we're doing as far
as violent crime
let's talk about the strategic plan it's
very important in my mind and it should
be in your mind too
on why we have a strategic plan and how
we function
as a department based on the strategic
plan so if you've heard me in the last
six years as your sheriff
one of the most important things i want
you to do is affect change
produce change adapt to change and
provide change
the environment we work in is changing
society changes the societal norms
change and what people accept and don't
accept
and the laws change so we have to adjust
accordingly
if we did what we did 30 years ago or 32
years ago when i was hired
we are not going to be able to do in
today's age so we have to adjust with
the strategic plans identifies those
particular issues
and help you affect that change i'm
assistant sheriff christopher darcy and
i'm here to talk to you today about the
strategic plan
the strategic plan really is a blueprint
for how we move into the future it helps
us get there
so as we move forward and we deal with a
significant amount of issues that come
before this organization
we can always reflect upon the strategic
plan to keep us focused on what we need
to do
it's a constant reminder when we look at
the goals it's how can we support these
goals with the actions that we're doing
out there every day within our community
and in the process of strategic planning
a variety of people on the agency
participate in
identifying the tactics and strategies
which we will employ to reduce crime
moving into the future the strategic
planning process is so important for
every organization in the valley but
specifically for the metropolitan police
department
because we are faced with numerous
challenges that involve the community as
well as our own organization and we all
have to work together to ensure that we
meet these challenges
the strategic plan should mean something
to every single officer
and employee within this organization
whether you're commissioned or civilian
you are part of the process by which we
are able to improve this agency through
that planning
process and we value your feedback and
we also value that you use it every
single day
in what you're doing so that way we can
stay on point and focus
so that we can achieve the vision
so the biggie covid i've had to make
adjustments and more importantly the
people on the street had to make
adjustments you know how they uh
communicate with an individual they
encounter they don't know what
what this person's been involved in they
don't know if they're positive for covia
they don't know their background
and all the extra responsibilities and
duties that you have to do on a daily
basis that you're not used to doing
and i think we've done a fantastic job
individually and as an organization
and adjusting to that environment and
i think we're probably getting pandemic
tired um
at this point just like the rest of
society and they're hoping it's going to
eventually
subside or go away you know your
protective gear
and how you wash your hands on a regular
basis and you know
you could take advantage of it and not
get close to people you never wanted to
talk to before anyway
so or you don't you're not comfortable
shaking people's hands anymore so you
have to figure out different ways to
meet and greet people and communicate
now the vaccines come on board
and people are in a quandary whether
they should get it or
or or is it mandatory is the sheriff
going to make it mandatory
i made a decision not um i think it it
falls under the collective bargaining
issue
if we make it mandatory i didn't want to
have to go that direction
but i personally absolutely advise you
to get the vaccine
to benefit you and your family members
and everybody you deal with on a daily
basis
i would really like people to evaluate
the need for the vaccine and come on
board
and do what's right in your own mind and
go and get the vaccine i had it myself
no issues
no symptoms some people have experienced
some slight symptoms like allergic
reactions
but all in all i believe it to be safe
and the science
is there so with all that being said
it's still
very important for our employees to
abide by the cdc guidelines
until everybody in society gets this
figured out it's important for people to
stay diligent
and and pay attention to all the
guidelines that are provided
by the folks that know more than we do
this is something that i never thought
that i would see in my entire career and
let's face it we were stepping into the
unknown we've none of us have ever dealt
with this
i'm kelly mcmahon and i'm the deputy
chief of the professional standards
division
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about this last year we had in dealing
with the covid19 pandemic
in those early days we had to come up
initially with a testing protocol
we had to come up with protocols of how
to report that you had symptoms of covid
i really have to credit health and
safety they went above and beyond and
today continue to be a seven day
operation where they're continually
taking phone calls from our employees
the biggest challenge with something
like this with a pandemic is that
honestly there's not a single thing on
this agency it didn't touch
it really was just across the board
something that every one of us had to
learn to
understand and live with and what kept
us awake at night was that we were going
to deplete our workforce
that really i think over this last year
is a thing that worried me the most
is that we just weren't going to have
enough of a workforce to continue to
provide the service to the community
that they deserved
but also keep one another safe out there
as executive staff we talked about what
our our mission was going to be and what
our goals were going to be
and number one was the health and
wellness of our employees and we knew
that
if our employees were worried about
their families if they're worried about
bringing something home to their
families
they weren't going to show up we really
had still a remarkable year
in regards to crime fighting while also
dealing with a pandemic and
it just goes to show that we really hire
the best of the human race here at lvmpd
i
absolutely believe that we were
resilient in the face of something that
we never expected and was completely
foreign to us and
that's why i love being here that's why
i love wearing this uniform
i have to really give credit to our
civilians that
we're told you work at a first responder
agency and so
if we're working the men and women in
uniform we need you here
we can't do it without you and without
missing a beat they continue to show up
for the the month and a half two months
that we had to send our volunteers home
i miss them too i think we i know we all
did right
it's it's a strange feeling to walk
around and not see anyone in a yellow
shirt
and so in order to keep them safe we
sent them home
but the day they came back i was pretty
happy to see them all here in the
building
as we move into the next phase of this
pandemic which is the vaccine is
available
i urge you all to get the vaccine please
in order to protect your families to
protect yourself
we do strongly strongly encourage you to
get the vaccine
and and i also strongly encourage you to
take care of one another
find the bright spots where you can it's
not always easy
and and try to have fun where you can i
know that it's been a long year
and i just want to thank every one of
the folks that work here i think we came
through this
stronger than we've ever been
so the other piece i want to talk about
is the budget because it's very
important
for people to understand our current
situation and what we anticipate is
going to happen into the future
um it's no secret we're going through
some budget
constraints some budget uh hard times
and people see that in society people
are out of work businesses are closed
associated with the covid and an
understanding of the budget
you know 30 percent of it comes through
the consolidated tax through the city
and the county
uh 30 percent through property tax and
30
say through sales tax and 10 percent of
self-generating
we receive a finite amount of money from
property taxes unless property taxes
increase that finite money is finite
uh sales tax has a big swing and that's
where we're affected the most
and that's where we hired the majority
of our police officers
on the police department through the
sales tax so and that sales tax is not
coming in because tourism aren't here
so what's on the back of my employees
minds am i going to get laid off
am i going to have a job tomorrow that's
the last thing i want you to worry about
especially when you're approaching a car
in the middle of the night and don't
know who's in the car i want you paying
attention who's in that car versus
whether you're going to have a job
tomorrow hopefully i don't eat my words
on this but i don't anticipate any pay
cuts
and i don't anticipate any additional
layoffs
we're relying greatly on the federal
stimulus
that we anticipate is going to come on
board but the tax numbers
are actually better than we predicted at
this point
and so i believe on the budget
issues and what we deal with on a daily
basis and what you have to be concerned
with
as an employee within the organization
there is some sunshine
associated with that my name is rich
hogan i'm the chief financial officer
here at
lbmpd i'm responsible for the
enforcement side of metro's budget
there the county is responsible for the
detention side of metro's budget
when the covent mitigation efforts
went into place the projections we had
at the time
were dire were very very very dire
we made a very conscious decision to
plan for every contingency but react to
what we actually knew
one of the strategies we had going into
it also was that our emphasis was going
to be
on preserving police officer and
corrections officer positions
and why is that we've gone to the voters
uh for
property tax initiatives uh sales tax
initiatives all of which were
were putting an additional burden on the
on the taxpayer
so to that end um as uh there were a few
functions that we eliminated
as positions became vacant as other
positions became vacant on the civilian
side we didn't fill them
as various rank and detective positions
which cost us a little bit more than a
standard
police officer position we became vacant
many of those were not
filled instead they were the positions
were put back to
patrol the combination of all those
along with our overtime reductions
um i i think has positioned us
pretty well going into next fiscal year
uh so the initial fear that we had
which was that uh in in fiscal year 20
in our
upcoming fiscal year that we would be
out of
essentially our savings and more cops or
fund balance
and out of our savings and crime
prevention act would have created the
perfect storm
but it looks like we've we've you know
dodged the worst of the
of the bullet if you will the challenges
we have on the detention side are a
little bit more significant we don't
have any
dedicated funding to the detention side
it's it's just strictly the county
contribution
uh we've cut where we could um but it is
a
uh it's going to be a a little bit more
of a difficult
uh challenge for us in next fiscal year
we don't anticipate
further cuts we don't anticipate layoffs
we don't anticipate requesting
cuts to cuts to salaries we are where we
need to be
assuming of course that nothing else
happens that we can't foresee
i've been amazed at how sensitive
most everybody is to our to our plight
and have really
taken it to heart and trying to help in
any way that they can
and all of it matters we are going to
get through this actually i am
optimistic
actually and and really um the vaccine
is what has what has created that that
optimism
and there's there's light at the end of
the tunnel that we
that we're likely to experience by a
return to some semblance of normality
from the vaccine's effects
so let's talk about police reform uh on
the hills of george floyd
but you know what i don't want to say on
the hills of george floyd let's let's
move back a couple years
and when we got audited by the
department of justice
in reference to our ois we saw the
writing on the wall we said hey we have
to make some
adjustments de-escalation was the key
component of our training
associated with that and all the
abilities to communicate verbal judo
everything that goes along with those
dynamic situations
and dealing with the people with mental
distress and the homeless
and everything else just made their way
into the police environment
we made adjustments and i'm very proud
of that and we publicized
all those things that go along with use
of force and dynamic use of force
we brought forward way before
george floyd move forward george floyd
all the
the eyes on law enforcement associated
with that and the need for reform across
the board
perceived need for reform across the
board
associated with that event okay
i embraced it i said what the officers
did associated with george floyd
was improper it was unprofessional and
it
didn't need to happen
but we have to be aware it did happen
and we have to be aware what society
perceives of law enforcement today
so i took it upon myself to say i got
your back i'm going to protect you
the local politicians here in las vegas
i'm very proud of the county commission
and the city council saying
yeah we're going to support you and a
direct result of that
is we had a decrease in crime
as compared to the other jurisdictions
that you're seeing the politicians are
pining on
the systemic racism and the
unprofessional
and the out of control police
departments
the police officers says no if you're
not going to support us we're not going
to support you
and i'm very proud of our police
department and the fact they say
this is what i signed up for this is
what i raised my right hand to do
and i'm going to do it as long as the
administration
supports me in my opinion i believe
my staff and myself is in full support
of what we do on a daily basis
and the proof is in the pudding we've
reduced crime
associated with 2020 where every other
jurisdiction in the united states didn't
and i'm very proud of that hello i'm
captain jim larochelle
from the office of the sheriff i'm here
today to talk to you about police reform
policy and the outcomes from the riots
that occurred this summer
the protests were something that we had
never seen before initially
we tried to catch up to the amount of
people that were protesting
we were surprised at the amount of
angst that was directed towards our
officers out in the street
our agency had done a number of things
to promote
reform throughout our history and we had
done a number of good things that were
recognized as best police practices
and here we were during the midst of the
protest that we were painted in the same
broad brush strokes as many agencies
across the country
so we had to go back and look at our
plans on how they're related to those
previous incidents and adjust them in
these protests
we were taking uh not only the initial
outcry but that
transformed as the night went on into
being on the receiving end of bad things
or rocks and bottles things thrown at us
that turned into skirmishes on those
protest lines between the protesters and
the police
really turning into a riot situation we
had to respond to those
i think our agency did a tremendous job
we showed restraint
and that said we did have officers hurt
and that was part of what we wanted to
go back and fix too is be able to
ensure that we're responding in a way
that's keeping our employees safe also
but also keeping in the mind the
community and also protecting the rights
of the people that were there
to make their voice known in a way
that's peaceful
and adheres to the constitution
so police reform is really about trying
to meet public's
expectations and you know certainly uh
anybody that's been in policing for a
generation has seen the public's
expectations change over time
the thought today is that i'm better
today than i was yesterday and i want to
be better tomorrow and the same thing is
with policing when we talk about reform
and certainly
today we use less use of force than we
did a generation ago
and that's a good thing and the idea is
not to eliminate
use of force in all circumstance the
idea is to
make good decisions on when and how you
use force to make sure that when you use
force it's necessary
we're not talking about handcuffing the
officers out in the street to do their
job
many times we're talking about here's a
way to do the job better here's a way
to move through your career and to
follow these guidelines
these expectations where you can have a
healthy career not impacted by something
negatively
we have initiated some of the very best
reforms
internally by ourselves from the start
when we talk about duty intervene
and sanctity life and pursuit policy
those are things
that lvmpd was a premier agency one of
the very first agencies
to incorporate and you're seeing other
agencies
do the same thing i do think that this
year that police reform will again be a
topic at the state legislative
session but having said that as i think
that lvpd is in good position
that we have set a high standard that we
have the best practices
we have the best policies and the best
training i am not nervous about
uh what will be enacted at the
legislative and how much it will affect
the way that we do business
you know without a doubt 100 certain
that our officers are
some of the best trained officers in the
country we have some of the best sound
policies
in the country that are well thought out
that provide clear direction and good
guidance
and likewise is that we do hold
ourselves accountable we do have good
oversight of our
our agency and so uh for us i think it's
a business as usual but having said that
we'll continue to
look around and incorporate new ideas
and that goes back again too is that
we're always looking to change to get
better
to be better than yesterday and to
improve upon what we're doing so don't
we don't get into that situation where
others are forcing us
to make the change so let's talk about
mental health and homelessness
it's unfortunately it's a key issue it's
a
quite often a response required
associated with those
two particular societal ills when a
community member is dealing with a
person in middle distress
or a homeless person camped out in front
of their place of business or residence
or
or wherever they may frequent on a daily
day daily basis
the answer to them is dial 9-1-1 so it's
not something that's going to go away
and it's not something that we can
ignore
so it's important for people to realize
that and that we
we responded to it in the appropriate
manner
and we realized that going forward as an
administration
and as an organization and develop tools
or give
the police officers in the response to
these particular issue tools to address
it
i'm deputy chief john mcgrath of the
tourist safety division
i'm here to talk about homelessness and
mental health going forward into 2021.
we started the homeless outreach team in
2018
and since we started that team we've
contacted over 20
000 people the homeless and the mentally
ill need help
and we are in the best position to be
the first
people to contact them and to try to get
them help
starting in 2020 we started to form
the behavioral health unit as part of
that behavioral health unit going
forward we have six
interns from unlv they're graduate
students in social work
and each of them are case managers for
some of the
what we call clients of that are that
we're trying to get more services to
and as we go in 2021 we really expect
that unit to to have more and more
results
we moved uh crisis intervention team out
of training and put them in
community engagement and so that section
now includes
crisis intervention the homeless
outreach team
and lima lima stands for law enforcement
mental health addiction we want to let
this las vegas community know
that we care about the issue of
homelessness
but we also understand that people that
are mentally ill
need help whether it's from us or us
referring them to a service or while
they're at jail
before they get out of jail at ccdc
whether we can get them
into a program where they'll be
getting assistance and not getting
arrested for
crimes that they commit and the jail
does a awesome job
of recognizing the problem we have at
the detention center
and as they get out what they call a
dismissal program
um trying to get them assistance as they
go forward you can't just give up you
have to keep trying
every time you contact someone it's an
opportunity
to get them off the street so we ask our
officers
to contact as many homeless as we can to
make sure that
maybe that's the day where they're going
to say yes to getting services
so the the outreach the referrals to the
services we're going to keep trying
we're not going to quit we're going to
do it better in 2021
well always an important piece and ever
since i've been your sheriff
my priorities have been violent crime
and last year we included
a quality of life and i think we're
going to continue in that vein
you know what i don't think we are going
to continue in that vein a lot of people
don't understand
30 percent of our tourism volume is
repeat customers
and if there's a perception in las vegas
that las vegas is not safe
we will not succeed as a police
department and what i mean succeed
is dealing with violent crime associated
with the depressed economy
and the ability to keep the workforce
robust and at the numbers that we need
to do
to be successful i'm ray spencer i'm the
lieutenant of the homicide section and
i'm here to talk about violent crime and
homicides
[Music]
2020 was a very busy year as an
investigator
it's a difficult year because what other
year has it been acceptable to walk
around with a mask on
there's no question from the sheriff to
all the leadership
on this department that we have geared
our focus towards reducing violent crime
we're the gold standard nationally when
you look at solvability rate it's at 94
and when you look at the national
average that's 60 percent
there's no other major city law
enforcement anywhere in the united
states that's close
to what we've done and i think that that
is a true testament to the
24 detectives the two investigative
specialists
and the four sergeants that work in
homicide when you look at homicide
specifically
but most importantly you know we can't
get away from the fact that the officers
that are out on the street
have done a tremendous job because we
would not be
anywhere near the success rate that we
have right now
if it wasn't for the patrol officers
that are out making those stops
and being proactive and doing the great
work that they're doing
if the community doesn't trust the
police department they're not going to
provide the tips
that we receive and because the trust
that we've built
we're getting a lot of those tips that i
don't think a lot of agencies are
getting
also our solvability percentage is so
high that the community has confidence
that when they report a crime and they
cooperate with the police
that we're going to solve that crime and
that's not just homicide that's robbery
that's burglary that's every crime that
we investigate on this agency
as an agency and as a community we need
to be very proud of that
our assistance that we're getting from
our digital forensics lab
out with the advancements in technology
are helping us solve
identify people quicker solve crimes
quicker
things that would not have been solved
10 years ago are getting solved
routinely
in 2020 and going into 2021.
the importance of making an impact on
shooting crimes is paramount and when
you look at
every 415a that we investigate
could potentially be a homicide that
we're investigating and when you look at
the impact that homicides and violent
crime have
everything that we can do to reduce
those numbers we need to make sure that
we're doing
that is where the work that the patrol
officers are doing on the street
i can tell you just from looking at some
of the involvement and cooperation
and hard work that they are doing that's
who we need to be looking at is the
success of this agency
all right so we made it through 2020
so you know the proverbial middle finger
we're gonna give that to uh
2020. and you know what let's look for
the light at the end of the tunnel folks
um we had a very tough trying year in
2020 i anticipate 2021
is going to be more positive you know
with the
onset of the vaccine people coming back
to las vegas to bolster the economy
and you know all the things that goes
along with the robust economy and a
quality of life community and in society
having a better perspective on their
daily
lives both with our family members with
internally
in our family and the community that we
deal with on a daily basis
and that we are required to serve and
that we're proud to serve
i want everybody to hold their chin up
high be proud of how we responded to
2020
and look forward to 2021 being a very
successful
positive forward moving year thank you
everyone